avec Sandrine Gomez bonjour Sandrine
bonjour fils
par la situation politique au
Royaume-Uni par ce coup de tonnerre avec
la démission de le stress effectivement
à cette démission elle s'impose
forcément à la Une de toute la presse
britannique non sans ironie vous allez
le voir regardez cette une tout d'abord
celle du gardien qui titres sur une fin
amer le journal écrit après 45 jours de
difficulté la première ministre humilié
s'incline devant l'inévitable le pays
lui se prépare avoir à arriver son
troisième Premier ministre cette année
pour le quotidien Métro il est
implacable la première ministre que nous
avons eu enfin c'est la pire première
ministre que nous ayons eu elles devront
donc ici regarder il y a Boris Johnson
qui est en embuscade le journal qui
rappelle donc ce mandat éclair inédit
dans l'histoire du pays et la question
qui se pose à la une des journaux bien
sûr c'est qui est en lice pour remplacer
l'histoire les journaux en spéculent
évidemment ce matin on va regarder la
une du Times Boris Johnson qui réfléchit
à retourner au pouvoir avec le départ de
listrot dans l'intérêt du pays nous
dit-on ici on nous raconte des
indiscrétions Boris Johnson est en
vacances dans les Caraïbes mais il a
déjà contacté ses alliés c'est donateurs
pour tâter le terrain il se dit être le
seul candidat aujourd'hui pour capable
de diriger le pays qui en a le mandat
puisque il a gagné au législatif c'était
en 2019 mais difficile toutefois d'y
croire regarder la une du Daily Express
il ne pouvait pas pourrait-il Boris
Johnson rebondir au 10 darning Street
aujourd'hui il dispose de 20 soutiens au
sein des touristes il en faut 100 on
souligne en tout cas que son retour
diviserait au sein du Parti conservateur
encore plus puisque trois députés au
moins se disputent à claquer elle
apporte alors essayez si le match retour
pourrait se résumer à cette affrontement
qualifié de match à mort ultime entre
Boris Johnson et Richie sunnac ici à la
une du spectator battu par listroth à on
s'en souvient lors de la final de la
désignation du chef du Parti
conservateur cet été donc Richie sunac
ancien ministre de la des finances
pardon il est lui aujourd'hui favori et
aussi parce qu'il incarne cette figure
rassurance de l'autodoxie budgétaire
donc ton besoin aujourd'hui les marchés
le mirror lui va droit au but regardé il
réclame et bien face au chaos des
élections générales maintenant c'est ce
que le peuple demande écrit le tabloïde
qui reprend ici la demande formulée hier
par le chef de l'opposition travailiste
kerstarmer qui condamne ce jeu de chaise
musicale à la tête du pays ça c'est pour
le Royaume-Uni dans votre revue de
presse également le Tchad et cette
journée meurtrières des manifestations à
l'appel de l'opposition qui ont viré au
drame oui des manifestations pour
protester contre le maintien au pouvoir
au maintien la tête de la transition du
président matma
Idriss Déby il y a eu au moins 50 morts
dans plusieurs villes 300 blessés on en
a parlé le journal aujourd'hui office
des titres sur ce début ensanglanté pour
la transition quereller pour ce journal
tout cela était prévisible un jeu cite
cette transition de 24 mois
supplémentaire que cet octroyer le fils
débit à l'issue du dialogue chahuté
portait en lui les germes d'une crise et
aller accoucher de graves difficultés
ici on parle de gâchis rien d'étonnant
non plus pour un autre
site d'information burkinabè le Waka
serra on déplore regarder des morts de
trop lors de ce Jeudi Noir ce feu Couvet
depuis la prise de pouvoir par les
généraux peut-on lire ici à douber par
une communauté internationale rassemblée
on s'en souvient dans la capitale
tchadienne à l'occasion des obsèques de
son père le fils d'eby était par contre
loin de bénéficier on vient de le voir
de l'onction de ses concitoyens voilà
c'est ce qui crie ce site en ligne une
répression que certains voudraient
associer à la France oui le journal du
chat titre regardait sur une répression
sanglante des manifestants et la France
qui se solidarise ce journal écrit je
cite la diplomatie française laisse
entendre que son pays n'est pas impliqué
on cite d'ailleurs le communiqué du Quai
d'Orsay qui condamne les violences au
Tchad et ajoute la France ne joue aucun
rôle dans ses événements pour le jelly
la revanche la France n'est pas si
innocente que ça dans cette répression
le journal guinéen considère ici que
mahammat
Idriss Déby et ses soutiens portent une
part de responsabilité mais aussi la
communauté internationale et la France
est fautive en premier lieu si on en est
là je cite c'est parce que la France a
couvé débit Suisse comme la poule et ses
poussins Matmat
Idriss Déby a eu droit à toutes les
protections et parallèlement les mises
en garde des opposants de trouver aucun
écho à Paris ou à Bruxelles une question
santé et un espoir dans le Figaro pour
ce qui était on l'a appris cette semaine
et c'est à dire dans le Figaro la
réussite de la deuxième grève du terus
en France elle s'est réalisée il y a un
mois et n'a pas été rejeté c'est un
exploit réalisé par l'équipe du
professeur Ayoubi à l'hôpital Foch de
Suresnes à Paris une femme de 36 ans a
reçu l'utérus de sa sœur de 41 ans c'est
donc un espoir pour de nombreuses femmes
à ce jour il faut savoir que cette grève
du Teri se déploie dans le monde entier
il y en a déjà eu 100 100 au total et il
faut on voilà il y aurait en tout et
pour tout 200000 femmes concernées en
France par cette nécessité de grève du
terrus il y a des femmes qui sont nées
sans utérus il y a aussi des femmes qui
ont eu des cancers par exemple merci
beaucoup Sandrine Gomez c'était la revue
de presse à retrouver sur le site France
24.com on marque une courte pause dans
Paris direct